bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission
rugby montigny-le-bretonneux continue sa
belle série les hommes coachés par le
duo cyril brighi mathieu green ont
remporté une victoire importante contre
le 4e hostens lors de la 13e journée du
championnat le score 15 à 13 les détails
dans ce magazine sport découverte
zoom sur le kayak polo dans cette
émission la discipline qui se pratique
sur le mélange l'orne balle le
basketball et le ok pour nous parler de
ce sport nous recevons sur ce plateau
marc stein président du club de
canoë-kayak de trappes et le vice
président stéphane bouchard cyclisme sur
piste après les championnats du monde le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines organisera les
championnats d'europe cette année du 19
au 23 octobre
reportage à suivre et puis l'essentiel
de l'actualité sportive du département
nous parlerons notamment des
championnats rênes du championnat
régional de gymnastique a été organisée
à ce week-end au palais des sports d'el
en cours
ont-ils bretonneux continua sa belle
série les hommes coachés par le duo
cyril mûriers gheist mathieu gré
troisième du championnat de première
série ont remporté une victoire
importante contre le 4e set 1 lors de la
13e journée du championnat le score 15 à
13 les images enseigné à camille lambert
c'est peut être l'un des tournants de la
saison pour montigny le bretonneux en
première série les verts ont remporté un
match décisif dans la course au podium
contre 7 1 ce dimanche à domicile dans
la boue et sous la pluie les y monte 1
se sont imposés à 15 à 13 a été
difficile à difficile à chercher ne du
match mais en s'en donner les moyens
et franchement c'est mérité
la joie était et est à 0 y crois que ça
n'a pas été facile on n'agit pas
l'habitude pâle l'abitrage mais
l'arbitrage en après nous a pas beaucoup
aidé mais les joueurs ont été héroïques
donc vous êtes rendus durant nous vous
avez dû vous en rendre compte qu'ils
sont narrés c'est une quinzaine de
minutes chez nous on n'a pas pris
d'essai ça c'est ça c'est fabuleux
il était très très très très très
discipline à ce niveau là avec cette
troisième victoire consécutive
montigny-le-bretonneux se relance dans
la course à la montée les joueurs
coachés par le duo cyril mûriers guy
mathieu gré occupe la troisième place du
classement à 11 points du deuxième col
imérien à quatre journées de la fin
beaucoup de temps sans à face 0 il ya
deux milliards de match
le mois dernier aussi on a réussi à
avoir le point de bonus on a réussi à
aller chercher une victoire dans un des
positions hors limites
pourquoi on vise la montée on fera tout
pour y arriver
pour continuer à rêver de la montée
montillot bretons ne devra
obligatoirement s'imposer contre shell
lors de la 14e journée du championnat un
match programmé au stade robert barran
le 20 mars prochain
après le rugby coup de projecteur sur le
cake paulo on continue donc ce magazine
par un sport presque inconnu du grand
public le kayak-polo la discipline est
un mélange entre le hockey le handball
et le basket ball et tout cela sur l'eau
pour nous parler de ce sport nous avons
le plaisir de recevoir sur ce plateau
marx talent le président du club de
canoë-kayak de trappes et stefan
bouchard vice président et responsable
de la section de cake pollock de trappes
bonsoir alors du hockey du handball et
du basket ball
c'est bon je me trompe pas dans ces
sports ça se rapproche de gaillac paulo
oui on peut le dire comme ça pour faire
pour faire court je pense que c'est un
sport qui plaît beaucoup aux jeunes
parce qu'il ya une une grosse un gros
engagement
son casque est grillagé donc voilà ça
fait un petit peu en effet rejet néral
donc on a on a développé cette pratique
là depuis plusieurs années parce qu'on
s'aperçoit que les jeunes aiment bien
donc on a commencé à faire des équipes 1
qui sont maintenant au 24 mai je
passerai la parole à mon collègue et on
travaille aussi sur une équipe féminine
b qui sera régional donc sinon il ya eu
aussi une pratique du kayak polo en
loisir c'est à dire que le vendredi soir
la piscine dans notre créneau d'activité
les jeunes peuvent s'entraîner ou kayak
polo et on vous a pris aux jeunes vous
le disais ça que j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
vous confirmerez on a une à une des
équipes les plus jeunes de la région
moyenne d'âge de 23 ans je suis plus
enfin non je parle plus parce qu'ils ont
un joueur qui à 62 ans c'est lui qui tua
- et
donc oui effectivement ça plaît
énormément aux jeunes
les équipes sont autour de la trentaine
ont en moyenne
il n'y a pas beaucoup de personnes pluie
et ce sport se rapproche de quelle
discipline j'ai parlé de hockey de
handball de basket ça sera en fête
tactiquement il faut imaginer le
handball sur l'eau
les défenses sont les mêmes sons défense
en zone sauf que nous n'avons pas de
zone vraiment marqué et dans l'impact ce
serait le hockey sur glace avec quelques
règles du hockey sur glace par exemple
on n'a pas la prison mais une expulsion
de deux minutes
si pour des fautes graves et
donc oui techniquement c'est le rendent
on ad on a le même joueur de joueurs des
pivots des et les actes est le même et
quelle qualité doit-on avoir pour être
un bon joueur de kayak polo
il faut savoir allier alors souvent on
pense que être simplement bon
reconnaître simplement le joue le jeu
c'est à dire au ballon suffit en fait il
faut être bon kaki c'est avant toute
chose parce que le bateau faut savoir
s'en servir et il faut avoir une qualité
physique aussi parce qu'on alterne les
efforts longs et les efforts dans la
durée et les efforts aussi rapide sur 20
mètres on a besoin d'accélérer donc au
niveau du rythme cardiaque sa célèbre
assez vite et c'est très physique
oui sur un match un match dure deux fois
dix minutes donc d'amener au total et en
général la fin on est bien bien fatiguée
et pour pratiquer ce sport il faut du
matériel spécifique les rames en
particulier ascendant spécifiques et les
pagaies de kpolo sont spécifiques au
kayak polo c'est à dire qu'elles doivent
faire une minimum d'épaisseur de 5 mm
pour éviter les chocs sur les mains et
les cakes sont mus et à l'avant et à
l'arrière pour protéger le l'adversaire
et les joueurs donc les rames et a
également le bateau le bateau également
le casque est grillagé et comme l'a dit
et marque
et puis les gilets qui sont pas des
gilets de monsieur tout le monde en fait
c'est léger et qui sont mus et surtout
les côtés pour pour protéger les côtés
et l'intégrité physique du joueur le
bateau est spécifique à ce sport
également à tout à fait heureux et ce
sont des petits bateaux qui doivent être
très bien devriez qui peuvent être très
rapides
ils sont souvent assez plat l'arrière
par rapport aux autres cagniac ce qui
permet aux joueurs de tourner en faisant
ce qu'on appelle une chandelle
il faut aller vite et du coup c'est les
bateaux sont faits pour aller vite
puis ces voix là ils sont très mal
d'ouvriers mais il faut qu'ils soient
analysés delà du dynamisme donc de la
vitesse on utilise les matériaux qui
sont faits pour se dire et pourquoi
avoir créé une section de kayak-polo
attrape la fois ce choix parce que été
fait il ya longtemps ce choix on vivait
il ya longtemps que ce choix est fait
bah c'est pour aussi fidéliser les
jeunes dans l'activité n'est pas on
n'est pas servie en rivières sur st
quentin en yvelines
donc on est bien obligés d'adapter notre
sport des pratiques qui permettent de
faire l'activité par exemple sur l'étang
de saint quentin où même les
entraînements aux piscines en ga écolo
c'est le côté pratique du vélo c'est
qu'on a pas besoin de d'une rivière on
n'a pas besoin d'un acte on n'a pas
besoin de la mer on a besoin d'un
endroit bien délimités avec des buts il
faut quand même assad et des buts et des
lignes de part et d'autre et il loisirs
de saint quentin en yvelines se prête au
cas où très bien même donc on a un
terrain
qui est en place à l'année mètres carrés
ça dans 35 $ par 20 de large
20 35 de long par 20 de large et donc on
en est à la base de loisirs consorts
l'hiver pour éviter qu'ils sabine et
donc les gens peuvent venir nous voir le
samedi après midi ou le dimanche matin à
l'entraînement et en france sa
discipline compte environ 2000 adhérents
vous vous comptez vous avez combien
d'adhérents dans votre club dans notre
club actuellement soit sur le kayak polo
orange veut pas juste sur lequel sur le
jeu sur un kayak polo 11 et une
vingtaine à peu près tête avec des
entraînements réguliers l'entraînement
le vendredi soir et quand le temps le
permet le samedi après midi et dimanche
matin et il ya de plus en plus de monde
du coup qui est intéressant on parlait
des jeunes tout à l'heure il y a de plus
en plus de monde qui est qui s'intéresse
aux cayes paulo où le sentais réellement
oui alors haut niveau au niveau national
oui on le sent vraiment parce que là
justement cette année là la fédé a
décidé de remodeler les divisions parce
qu'en fait elle s'aperçoit qu'il ya de
plus en plus de monde donc pour
dynamiser les championnats régionaux
elle a décidé de réduire la n4 à 14 pour
l'année 2016 2017
donc cette année on est 3 poule 2 11
et sur ces trois poules de langil
restera que 14 équipes et donc il y à
des compétitions où vous le disait et
trappes participent à ces compétitions
oui donc non participe au championnat de
france nationale 4
qui commencera pour l'équipe de trappes
le 3 avril a assigné en bretagne et les
travaux organisé deux journées
cette année une le 17 avril et l'autre
le nom de faire la base la ligne de
loisirs de saint quentin côté base de
voile rendez vous est pris en tout cas
vous pouvez vous nous donner envie en 30
secondes de faire du kayak polo de nous
lancer dans cette aventure j'ai trente
secondes c'est un sport convivial
enfin si vous avez la nature le contact
et ne pas s'enfermer dans une salle
c'est le sport qu'il faut il faut il se
fait pour les aventuriers c'est ça et
puis c'est le cac est une grande famille
donc ça me suis bien au delà du sport en
lui-même
merci à tous les deux d'être passé sur
ce plateau si vous voulez plus de
renseignements sur le kayak polo est
sûre le club de trappes l'adresse du
site internet apparaît en ce moment même
à l'écran après le kayak polo au tour
sur une terre de sueur sur terre avec le
cyclisme sur piste
les amateurs de cyclisme sur piste vont
une nouvelle fois vibrer au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
après les championnats du monde
organisés en février 2015 l'enceinte
sportive organisera les championnats
d'europe en octobre prochain le montage
est signée à pascal josèphe
c'est désormais officiel après les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste 2015 le vélo tome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines organisera les
championnats d'europe cette année du 19
au 23 octobre
une initiative lancée par la fédération
française de cyclisme en partenariat
avec la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
il ya une certaine logique il ya d'abord
une logique d'accueillir de grands
événements on a la chance d'avoir un
vélodrome exceptionnel quand on a vu
l'élan qu'on a eue au championnat du
monde
on a eu envie finalement de continuer à
avoir des grands événements on avait
cette opportunité puisque 2017 étaient
déjà attribués à berlin 2018 à glasgow
et on a saisi l'opportunité pour cette
deuxième compétition internationale
organisée par le vélodrome les instances
françaises espèrent remplir les 5000
places de l'enceinte sportive pendant
l'ensemble de la compétition
on ne s'est fixé un objectif il ya cinq
jours de compétition c'est cinq jours le
vélodrome plein comme les chauffeurs du
monde 25 mille personnes on doit pouvoir
y arriver
c'est vraiment ce que l'on ce que l'on
souhaite ou chemin france on avait déjà
beaucoup de monde je mets du monde
vendu 60 % des billets le premier jour
vient le chemin d'europe doit se faire
avec un vélodrome à guichets fermés
le public pourra voir des têtes
d'affiché comme la plaisir oise 110
claire championne d'europe de vitesse en
2010 ou encore ligne montrent un
françois pervis six fois champion du
monde favori pour obtenir une médaille
aux jeux olympiques l'été prochain à rio
le fc trappes 50 ans ni vie n'en finit
plus de gagner de remonter au classement
les hommes de mustapha el hafidi se sont
imposés a89 a72 contre melun à domicile
dans un véritable festival offensif
conséquence trappe remonte doucement
classement les joueurs de tra pointent
désormais à la 5e place du championnat
de nationale 3 pour nous parler de cette
très bonne dynamique nous recevons sur
ce plateau jacques michel et le
président ainsi que le coach mustapha el
hafidi est habillé baraka où le meneur
bonsoir alors je le disais encore une
victoire ce week-end contre moulins et
quelle victoire
plus de quasiment 20 points d'écart oui
ça a été une très bonne victoire et je
pense que malgré on parlera plus que moi
parce qu'il a vécue sur le terrain
habillez vous l'avez senti comment sa
dette mais c'est vrai que dès le début
du match on était comme depuis quelques
matchs bien dans le match défensivement
offensivement on a déroulé et puis la
victoire est venue s'est construit très
rapidement au monde à gérer
du début à la fin moi ça va vous misé
beaucoup sur la défense en général dans
vos matches là pour le coup c'est
l'attaqué a parlé alors la dernière fois
j'ai dit ça j'ai pas vous expliquer en
fait ben ali est là pour l'attester
je pense que le basket c'est vraiment du
côté du terrain donc on fait et attaque
et défense et c'est vrai que cette année
on à la porte quand même deux trois
joueurs d'un très bon niveau
biella il y avait deux gars et il ya
aussi des jouets cassés us qui arrivé
cette saison et qui apporte à
l'intérieur vraiment une arme offensive
et défensive qui est incroyable
collectivement vous avez été meilleur à
billets sur cette rencontre ça fait
depuis quelques matches qu'on est con on
est bien collectivement depuis quelques
mois depuis quelques mois il a juste
fallu qu'on apprenne à se connaître et
depuis depuis ça on déroule et vous avez
déroulée sur ce match vous aviez je
crois 22 points d'avancé ça où on
m'avait dit jacques 22,22 points
d'avancé à la mi temps
vous êtes satisfait j'imagine de des
jours de trappes
bien sûr bien sûr on avait dit en début
de saison qu'on allait avoir un début de
saison délicat encore que j'étais pas
certain d un premier résultat mais il
était probable que on serait en rodage
ce que nous avons été avec quand même
trois matches qui ont été perdue de
justesse et contre les contres les
premières équipes
et puis depuis depuis décembre en fait
depuis décembre comme didier ben
l'équipe commence à dérouler parce que
ils forment un groupe
alors bien sûr il y à il ya tout
l'aspect technique que que présente
mostafa mais plus que ça je crois que
cette année on peut dire qu'on a
vraiment affaire à une équipe de copains
qu'on a affaire à une solidaire ce qui
n'avait pas été peut-être le cas sur les
dernières saisons ce qui avait été plus
difficile des dernières saisons parce
qu'on on avait subi des difficultés
extérieures qui avait joué sur le climat
interne
cette année c'est pas le cas cette année
il y a vraiment une construction il a
fallu que les joueurs apprennent à se
connaître
apprennent aussi la technique
individuelle et collective de mostafa
ski si si ce qui est bien sûr quelque
chose qui ne concerne pas très très
courant il n'a fallu que les joueurs
s'adaptent bien sûr mais maintenant ça
déroule effectivement
donc là on en est à bille à un bilan de
10 victoires 6 défaites en 16 matches
disputés c'était un bilan attendu ou
même ce bilan là vous surprend mostafa
attendu non me surprend non plus mais ce
qui est bien c'est qu'effectivement le
le groupe ou renforcée par des joueurs
d'expérience à 1000 certes un peu de
temps mais s'est mis au niveau des
autres joueurs et ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a une homogénéité en
fait dans notre jeu est effectivement on
arrive à gagner le samedi matin je sais
pas ce que sera le week-end prochain
parce qu'on leur a chaque fois même si
l'écart était défi était facile ce
week-end c'était pas un match facile en
soit le dernier quart temps on a perdu
un peu de concentration et elle est
quand même de quasiment 20 points oui on
gagne de quasiment 20 points mais encore
une fois il ya l'expérience de joux 10,2
de deux joueurs parce que là j'ai cité
trois joueurs mais effectuera deux
joueurs vraiment d'expérience et ce qui
est bien c'est que les jeunes arrières
se mettent à leur niveau mais parfois la
jeunesse revient au galop et
et ce match on aurait pu le gagner de 30
points ça n'a pas été le cas vous êtes
exigeants non c'est pas d'exigences
c'est juste c'est un moment donné si on
veut aller plus loin il faut que tout le
monde respecte
notre langage commun parce que ça ce qui
a été aussi long à mettre en place et on
a eu de la chance encore une fois
d'avoir deux personnes qui sont
complètement investi dans le club pour
cette équipe là est ce qui a permis en
fait de switcher vers quelque chose de
positif pas que je dois négative parce
qu'au mois de novembre s'était passé
simple que ça et ce bilan à bigs et de
17 victoires en 16 matches disputés vous
vous y attendiez vous en début de saison
vous qui venez d'arriver au club en
début de saison comme l'a dit le coach
il fallait que l'on apprenne tous à se
connaître
pas le même langage donc on n'a pas fait
de deux plans
on s'est dit qu'on allait avancer phase
après phase quant à étaient prêts à
gagner on a plus pensé à la défaite
donc j'ai pas fait de plan au début de
saison à l'heure d'aujourd'hui voilà jeu
comme dirait le coach en avant ce match
après match mais c'est vrai que on part
confiant on travaille comme une équipe
de haut niveau des entraînements de haut
niveau on joue un jeu un basket de haut
niveau donc alors d'aujourd'hui c'est
vraiment vraiment que du positif par
rapport au jeu et on sait que l on est
confiant pour la suite
et la mayonnaise finalement appris assez
rapidement la monnaie zapperi voilà on
nous avait dit que ça viendrait au bout
de vingt mois
c'est venu au bout d'un mois même un peu
plus tôt mais après la fois le juste
qu'on se rende compte de ce qu'on avait
entre les mains et c'est ce qu'on a fait
moi savent pas comment créer une
cohésion d'équipé
quand on a des nouveaux joueurs qui
arrivent d'un peu partout comment créer
cette cohésion d équipe et surtout il
faut la créer rapidement cette collision
effectivement et je suis pas le seul
artisan
parce qu'en fait souvent pense que les
coaches sont des magiciens et à chaque
fois je le répète ici on pense que la
fausse humilité ne savais pas du tout en
fait tout le mérite revient constamment
joueurs les dynamiques de vous prévient
jamais d'une personne vient de
l'intérieur et je sais que par exemple
ils ont une réunion un jour et suite à
cette réunion
le comportement de tout le monde a
changé lors des mac et ce moment que les
prises de conscience
je pense qu'une prise de conscience erc
encore une fois un groupe c des
individus et et plurielle et je ne peux
pas être omniscient omnipotent au sein
d'un groupe c'est impossible
donc si on adhère message c'est très
facile de donner un contenu parce que
j'ai un contenu mais si on adhère pas ce
message dans son contenu
très vite il n'existe pas plus parce que
il dépend de celui qui de fait est le
réceptacle de ce contenu jacques
que pensez vous du travail de mostafa
avec ce groupe je suis exactement dans
les mêmes dispositions d'esprit que ce
que rien d'expliquer mostafa c'est pour
ça vous l'avais choisi je crois qu'il y
avait quelque chose de fly avec
maintenant quelques années mais c'est
tout à fait vrai mais je dirais que en
fait c'est pas simplement là comment le
groupe comme ça c'est pas quelque chose
de magique
ce ne sont pas des individus non plus
c'est la qualité de la relation entre
les individus et cette réunion d'en
parler on parle mostafa qui a été
l'initiative des joueurs qui se sont
auto organisés auto organisé à partir
d'un esprit qu'on a essayé de donner à
partir de principes de principe n'ont
pas sportif seulement mais de principes
humains ce justement de pourquoi on est
là qu est ce qu on veut faire ensemble
et donc peut-être sous la responsabilité
du capitaine
faux pas il faut pas faut pas non plus
minimiser l'importance de sautes de
cette initiative mais avec l'accord pas
simplement de lui mais d autres
également ils se sont coordonnés ils ont
créé une qualité de liens ce langage
commun on parlait tout à l'heure mostafa
et c'est ça qui pour moi explique
explique nos résultats
je dois dire aussi que on n'a pas
seulement ça mais je pense que chacun
d'entre nous respecte cet esprit
respecte les autres
humainement et du point de vue également
je dirais de de l'esprit structure en se
structurant l'équipe et le club
a brigué la montée c'est pour cette
année on a pris du retard
elle a pris du retard clairement au
début de saison on n'avait pas programmé
ça non plus
on aura peut-être une ou des défaites en
moins voilà peut-être le diakhaté
conférence avec le après on va pas
parler de ça nous comme je vous ai dit
c'est les matches les uns après les
autres
il faut que tout soit mis en oeuvre pour
pour la montée peut-être que l'année
prochaine ce sera le cas si les
dirigeants le décide
si les instances politiques le décide
aussi tout et sera mis en oeuvre pour
monter après sportivement à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui on est on est prêts on
comme je le dis on travaille bien on
joue bien on défend on a tous le même
langage
maintenant les objectifs du club ce sera
des dirigeants de les fixer
l'entraîneur et pourquoi pas oui les
dirigeants sont aussi un peu dépendant
si je peux me permettre un peu de la fin
ça va de la politique globale d'un
département et d'une ville parce que
malheureusement un club sans subvention
à un moment donné est un club qui est
voué à à l'extraction est aujourd'hui le
combat il est là il faut savoir que la
majorité des joueurs aujourd'hui je joue
comme des bénévoles au club
c'est pour ça que je vous dis qu'il ya
une dynamique qui est exceptionnel les
il faut dire merci à b parce que ce
qu'il faut savoir sur son parcours c'est
que partout où il est passé
ça a été un homme de vestiaire et un
homme qui a fait monter les clubs où il
est passé
donc donc clairement clairement vu la
situation aurait pu être totalement
délétère au mois de novembre alors que
nous étions prêts à gagner au moins
d'octobre et je pense que par ces mots
dans le vestiaire il a et finalement
vous avez dérapé
oui mais encore une fois c'est une
synergie est ce qui manque aujourd'hui
c'est le soutien de la mairie il faut le
dire clairement
merci en tout cas tous les trois dettes
passées sur ce plateau bon courage pour
la suite de la compétition on passe
maintenant à la gymnastique
c'est l'un des premiers gros rendez vous
de la saison à ne pas manquer pour les
gymnastes francilien le championnat
régional était programmée à ce week-end
au palais des sports à d'elancourt plus
de 300 sportifs ont participé à la
compétition une équipe a brillé à cette
occasion le jem et l'encours maurepas à
collecter 11 médailles zoom sur cette
équipe
camille lambert pour les images des
acrobaties des sous à plusieurs mètres
du sol ce week-end au palais des sports
d'elancourt le public a pu assister à
une compétition de haute voltige à
l'occasion du championnat régional de
gymnastique pour ce rendez vous le club
d'elancourt maurepas organisateurs de
l'épreuve faisait figure de favori
tout en les préservant parce que quand
on est en plein hiver elles sont un
petit peu fatigué c'est pas une période
où le le corps et la physiologie sont à
leur maximum dont il faut les préserver
mais on a essayé de faire un travail qui
soit approprié à la période et tient la
préparation d'une compétition parmi la
quinzaine de gymnastes du club engagé la
plupart sont encore en période de rodage
en vue du top 12 de compétition élite
programmé le 19 mars prochain dans la
commune de mouilleron le captif en
vendée le championnat régional fait donc
office de répétition générale
c'est là où je vais tester pour voir où
j'en suis après ça pas une grosse
pression mais c'est pour vraiment voir
ce que je peux faire c'est une des
premières dates qui est importante
puisque
on prépare voilà c'est vraiment la
dernière compétition pour préparer le
top 12
donc on y tient
on tient de l'importance dessus
maintenant
on reste
encore en préparation donc on verra il
ya des petites choses à à fignoler à la
fin de cette compétition
au total le club des longs cours bord
pas à glaner 11 médailles pendant la
compétition zilli leriche 11 ans a
notamment remporté la médaille d'or avec
plus de 11 points d'avance et barlen
maille est monté sur la plus haute
marche du podium
on commence à trouver que résultats par
du trampoline le 2e open sélectif et la
coupe d'ile-de-france est déprogrammée
ce dimanche au gymnase de l'aviation à
guyancourt
une centaine trampolinistes se sont
inscrits pour l'événement objectifs de
chaque athlète se qualifier pour les
championnats de france
l'entraîneur du club de guyancourt nous
présente la notation des épaules il
était au micro de sephora anomalie sur
chaque exercice on va avoir deux notes
avant une note qui est l'exécution de la
qualité de réalisation de l'exercice
s'appuie sur les tensions de jambes les
bras bien tendus la tête tenue et une
note qui est sûre les la difficulté de
l'exercice même que sur les différentes
figures réalisées lui il ya tour plus
elles sont difficiles et plus la
difficulté est élevé au niveau des
résultats ni cas sachez du club de
guyancourt a terminé à la quatrième
place dans la catégorie nationale 13 14
ans et a réalisé les minima pour les
championnats de france
chez les garçons liane cas béland a lui
terminé quatrième dans les 4 13 14 ans
n'a pas obtenu les minima pendant ce
rendez vous c'est la fin de 7,8 sport
merci d'avoir suivi je vous souhaite une
très belle soirée sur tv fil 78